diese verstecken ich habe die beste idee
kommt es jetzt mache
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem super smash mob seine super smash
rollmops runde zusammen mit war zusammen
mit fanny und mit christoph erst mal
hallo hallo ich habe ausgewählt du hast
nämlich stünde am besten nimmt die
spinne wenn es geht es gut ich nehme ich
auch gar keiner der bislang seien
jedenfalls was wir machen ist stani hat
minecraft damals gewonnen das ist schon
ein bisschen länger her allerdings haben
wir nun halt jetzt endlich ein termin
gefunden gedacht jetzt wollt jetzt
keiner management machen deswegen machen
wir ein paar runden hier auf meinen
plexi wir zusammen spielen hier links
danke danke ein paar leute die mir tipps
gegeben haben hierfür und zwar vor
chance
nein ich bin direkt runter gefallen und
zwar dass ich zum beispiel auch beiden
blätter kopf steuern kann uns so
jedenfalls wollten wir jetzt hier ne
runde aufnehmen für meinen kanal dann
kommt morgen noch eine runde domination
beispielsweise auf catania lps kanal
findet ihr alles in der beschreibung und
christoph ist einfach auch so dabei und
das machen wir jetzt vier runden lang
dann können wir auch immer runden bei
sat 1 ihr euch angucken und das wird auf
jeden fall hammer wichtig
und ja dann jungs was habt ihr für das
trapani hier der tour down und chris
haben
du kannst recht machen und was alles an
hast du so ein paar extra features
anderen typen da kenne ich kenne das mit
papier sehe neben der typ da hast du
noch jetzt scheiße ich habe noch zwei
leben christoph aufzuteilen ja noch drei
chris martin geht an die erst mal machen
oder das west mit diesen creeper bitte
rausschmeißen hat einige nicht auf mich
nicht und ich weiß jetzt diesen keeper
christoph schröer ist doch lass uns
drüber wir gehen jetzt auf diesen krieg
schild da oben wir müssen jetzt so hoch
steigen also ich hab ich auch nicht aber
ich kann mit meiner dings wir müssen
hier hochkommt versucht jeder
hochzukommen wie man jetzt taktik so
miteinander gekämpft hätten versucht von
hier so ein bisschen weil ich dann die
sonne peschl feuer giesst attacke dass
ich hier mit seinem sohn über kopf
stellen kann
er denkt so er macht explosion aber
schadet mir fern ich bin oben runter an
roter fleck wir noch ein bisschen mehr
zu tage hat das finde ich das bin ich
er boxt mich direkt wir gehen jetzt auf
hohem alter wo ist er denn du bist der
typen da ist ja besser desto besser
magica text habe ich hab ganz gut
getroffen
ok es explodiert sich mal selber ja man
erst tot ich habe getötet
bild oliver patek satan du musst auch
mitspielen oder das heißt oder das lag
bei mir einfach immer so ist es
gewitterte tores du bist tot sein leben
während das beiden ich denke ich werde
gewinnen nein es ist auch noch drin
lasst uns erst auf den olymp
zusammenhängen ich sehe du bist da
dieses skelett des wahrscheinlich wieder
hoben am campen denken oder geh ich hoch
und mappus ich denke wir müssen jetzt
hier lebst du noch aber dann regeneriere
ich erstmalig die jetzt so oft kommt
was für kontakte fallen weil sie vorher
ist das erste oben ich weiß nicht ich
komme da oben nicht in alter alleine
gegen den ich weiß aber nicht umhin
komme
du musst du musst gesamten muss aber
doppelt machen so nach oben noch mal und
noch mal verliebt
ich komme nicht mehr hoch nicht immer
wieder mit ich gehe wieder weiter runter
zu verstecken ich hab eine bessere idee
kommt jetzt mache
mach mein image nicht kaputt
da kann man sich dann im virtuellen ich
musste doch irgendwie hoch kommen vor
allem aus der doppel job ich komme immer
nur so ein bisschen hoch ich komme ja
ich schaff das nicht dass es vor der
chempark in camp hope ley enormen spaß
da oben nur um hockt was hatte ich aber
auch mal einfach rum
er macht einfach nix er sitzt einfach
darum aus einer scheiß plattform weiter
wer sich vermutlich aus
da sieht man schon immer fragen kann man
ja gucken ist schon irgendwie mal
gewonnen
ich hab mich geworden weil er zwei leben
ich hätte eh alle gefischte day oh ich
hab noch zwei herzen ich auch nicht
spectator ein was ich hab noch ein leben
ok damit jetzt muss ich richtig
vorsichtig vorgehen ich heiße ok erst
mal den kopf und jetzt im himmel dort
jetzt weiter drauf da beide darauf auf
dem ja okay ist tot
wir beide noch einen leben beide noch
ein leben puh jetzt wird's spannend
spannend
ich hab geworden da da da da er ist
einfach da morgen morgen sieben dritter
nur wenn er kam ja es hat einfach raus
geflogen
egal wir noch ein einzel und erhielt er
dann und dann sofort wieder so dass wir
wieder zurück super smash mops diesmal
wir drei und ein anderer typ ich nehme
jetzt mal die neue which klasse und
wieder ein quiz bei fast nicht es ist
wieder da ja ja egal die kripo auf jeden
fall einfach zu töten wenn er nicht
gerade irgendwie rum camp ribas auch
nicht so stark eigentlich place on
unglaublich stark dann haben sie mir
alle geschrieben in die kommentare und
witsch ist jetzt ganz neu dazugekommen
auch halloween modi die ich
wahrscheinlich noch mal eine spielen
werde weiß noch keiner so richtig ultras
auf diesem server wir gehen erst mal
wieder auf den kripo machen ich bin
jetzt redet sie die kekse hier scheiß
ich dachte schon wieder mit meiner
mutter trägt ihr vorgehen ich kann so
fledermäuse schleudern und alles und so
tränke schmelzen aber die laus unglaube
habe die klasse ist unglaublich schwach
oder ich kann damit einfach nicht
umgehen
das ist mal wieder nein nicht auf mich
gehen nicht auf mich junge tharani
christoph ich höre dir ich seit
ewigkeiten nicht auf mich wir gehen
jetzt auf christoph das ist unglaublich
sagt ihm nicht auf mich hat er geht
einfach auf mich nehmen wir gehen jetzt
alles
auf den körper nicht komplett angebot
der lufthansa wiederum konnte von
anderen seite ja und was kann ich dafür
ich bin wieder hochgekommen ist okay
wenn ich mal in dem netz ein
diese klasse diese which klassen der
getöteten ist es irgendwie so ich konnte
überhaupt nicht klar
dieser typ hat aber nur noch ein leben
lassen eben runter zwingen und dann dann
ist es doch wenn ich die schon rum
lampen sehen kriegt die krise hier wird
so kommen jetzt schwer mit ihm die sonne
gang und dann bomben mit den eltern und
ich bin einfach ich bin einfach
gestorben
okay er hat noch einleben müssen wir
jetzt einfach mal drauf gehen ganz hier
nicht alleine bestens mit gezogen oder
so dass meine flügel die mich mit einher
junge christoph du brauchst nicht immer
du bist immer hat die flüge können mich
rum mit
ich hatte dich ich hasse dich wie franke
und tod sind das für vögel viecher weil
sie häufig mit ziehen wenn ich das
drücke
ja wir haben gegen drei wie sonst nur
drei leben können das seien jedoch nicht
hast du viel auf einmal los geschneidert
das ist diese knochen explosion stirbt
das treffen nicht
ja ja nein richtig geil aus nein aber
ich verbinde damit die schlechteste
klasse die ich je genommen ich hatte dir
jetzt bleiben aber trotzdem drin in der
lobby in zwei jetzt wenn das vorbei ist
wir müssen immer noch zusammen drin sein
wissen immer noch zusammen oder naja ok
ich deswegen kann mir jetzt direkt noch
was aufnehmen den nehme ich denn diesmal
dass du dich die ich mir man sich kaufen
kann
mir wurde gesagt die sollen das
playstation hier nicht um die sprinter
war okay diesmal machen wir wird wir
drei machen team und gehen zuerst dass
wir diesen steve jobs kicken es machen
wir die mammuts und jetzt boxen einfach
direkt er wird einfach direkt sterben
ein konto oder kennt nicht egal wer
trotzdem direkt sterben englisch auch
egal was er isst er ist einfach nichts
hat einfach keine kleinvach nicht jetzt
ein normalsterblicher mit ihnen direkt
auf den wir gehen direkt auf ihn wenn
irgendeiner von uns anderen boxern gehen
wir nur noch auf den der uns box also
christoph wenn du uns tötet auf einmal
ok ich sehe ihn ich wissen was sie
machen luca
war das egal
ich bin einfach runter gesprungen
einfach runter ich muss erst mal gucken
was ich kann leipzig firefly ich weiter
hier gegen den firefly ist ein
ich muss erstmal wieder hinsichtlich von
zeugen ein interesse an greifen
ich habe den auf milch [ __ ] euch auch
dass dieser typ da oben entfernt was
machen was ist das alter das ich daher
nur selber weg ich verstehe das gar
nicht das ist schon das zweite mal jetzt
ich weiß das ist ja wohl der sco der typ
ist auch down noch einmal hatte ich habe
noch ein leben erst hoch ist komplett ok
los gehts jetzt beginnen sollte wenn ich
das gewinne damit skinner hoch 3000 auf
die alten christoph wir leben noch
erst recht mit ihrem wachstum drin
gerade und ich kann geschlagen und
können wieder mit den eigenen reihen
ich habe mich wieder mit meinen eigenen
attacke weggeboxt er wiederum tanja nur
zwei leben auf einmal christoph nur noch
zwei leben auf einmal weil ich dachte
einmal fest natürlich gilt das in ruhe
luca das ist ihm machen ich boxe mich
immer selber weg mit meinen attacken was
ist
ich heiße ja eine komplett tot alter
weil ich boxe mich ich mach mir immer
ich würde so eine attacke von mir ein
ich hab zu 15 weniger auf einmal sich
die behindert egal wie beide müssen
gewinnen bin ich so rum und springen
dagegen als zweiter der hätte styling
noch eine runde hinter welcher dann
machen wir jeder gegen jeden der
nächsten runde aber wirklich jeder gegen
jeden da wird sich wohl fühlt die nehme
ich denn jetzt ich glaube ich bin
einfach wieder beim eda mit da bin ich
am erfolgreichsten
damit ist ulla einem skelett rottbeck
taken damit man sieht ja die werte bei
wigan oder oder solchen schicken
schicken es eigentlich auch ganz geil
aber ich nehme nicht nehmen ich nehme
den neuen kraftstoff gehen fallen
leise hier auf einmal war es dann los
mit meiner audiospur ach mensch trägt
man über steuern auf jeden fall so jungs
alle gegen alle alle gegen alle habe ich
gehört
wieso bin ich denn jetzt wieso bin ich
skelett ich hab doch spinner ausgewählt
das noch mal wie du warst bei mir direkt
mal die getötet er ist nicht so dass die
alte
nein und ich fand einfach so runter ich
hoffe einfach weiter 19 wie ksb
hochklettern satanik panik ja was das
was die kleine spinne nur einfach
doppelsprung das bist du jetzt die vier
alles einfach mal auf den namen achten
ich bin ja alle was mit mir los du bist
dritte
nein wie kannst du überleben
ich habe nur ganz wenig herzen natürlich
ist mein christoph gibt es ja nicht
was war das ich hatte eigentlich kein
herz mehr
trotzdem gerät und christoph man sagt du
tot an den richter
er weist alle gegen uns beschwert sich
der mars sein
klickt euch was hat das ich bin zum netz
scheiße ja wohl egal aber dugard noch
ein leben erst andere typ der da oben
die darum wer kommt christoph eins gegen
eins kann damit jetzt ein rückgriff auf
dem ich mich nicht ein leben nicht ein
er denn fit macht erwacht hat keinen
einfluss drauf
der typ gewand mit zwei anderen einige
verlierer treffen als die anderen wo der
ball artisten auf mich toll sieht die
denkt so zwei spielen die halten so
zusammen guck mal der macht nicht mehr
was christoph kranich von der typen
airbus uns alle
da kann ich machen
leute das war hier mit spox wenn ihr
nomination sehen wollt könnt ihr einfach
morgen bei ca die vorbeigucken
gastrobereich gefallen hat will zu
meinen daumen hoch auf jeden fall freuen
und dann